now that the campaign has started
DeSantis is punching back here he is
smacking down Trump on Disney and
immigration
Trump I think a lot of conservatives you
know we kind of laugh when you hear it
but a lot of conservatives believe that
a trump the Santas or DeSantis Trump
ticket is unbeatable real quick thought
on that and then we'll go into some some
of the other stuff
yeah I
thinks he's been attacking me on I've
been a little surprised at because he's
attacking me from the left and that
really wasn't the Donald Trump from 2015
and 2016. I mean he was a hard charger
leaning in on all the issues very edgy
on conservative issues and it was part
of the reason he did so well but when
he's taken Disney side against me I just
kind of Wonder like okay I get he wants
to hit me but don't take the side of a
multinational corporation that wants to
sexualized kids he's also hitting me
against voting against immigration
amnesty there was the good lat 2 bill in
2018 and he said that that is akin to
voting against the wall but that bill
was a two million person amnesty for
illegal aliens very little money for any
border security all conservatives
opposed it he did support it as
president which a lot of us were upset
about but to hit me for being taken the
America first position I just think is a
little little strange so I'm not sure
what his strategy is but I think he's
taking positions that are a little bit
different than uh than four or five
years ago okay so that's good note it's
not a person attack right he's actually
quite clearly criticizing two of the
attacks on him so what are those two
attacks he's basically saying hey Trump
because you don't like me you're
basically backing and defending Disney
which we know is true right that's what
he's been doing and then interestingly
on the immigration one if you if you're
not fully paying attention to what
DeSantis was saying there if you're not
fully aware when Trump wanted money for
the wall it was also going to include
that two million illegals were get going
to get to stay here they were going to
get amnesty that is why DeSantis voted
against it it wasn't that he wasn't for
the wall he was for the wall but didn't
want that to also be attached to these
two million people staying here so this
this concept of trump attacking him from
the left I think is gonna this is this
is Trump if you're watching I don't
think this works I don't think this
works to be like I'm more of a lefty I'm
for more amnesty than desantises and I'm
for I'm more Pro Disney and even though
I was the one that was supposed to Roy
the woke when the guy comes in and
actually is destroying the woke I'm
gonna try to destroy him
[Music]